noting that more than half of gaza's
population has now fled their homes and
are living in appalling conditions un
officials accused Israel of violating
international law the current Siege
imposed on Gaza is collective
punishment two weeks of full Siege
followed by the trickle of Aid last week
mean that basic services are crumbling
medicine is running out food and water
are running out fuel is running out the
UN and several member states repeated
their call for an immediate humanitarian
ceasefire according to the Palestinian
Ministry of Health more than 8,300
Palestinians have been killed in Gaza
including over 3,400 children with over
6,300 children
injured this means that more than 420
children are being killed or injured in
Gaza every day a number that should
shake each of us to our core
Brazil and other nations warned that
time was running out for civilians as
the security Council tries yet again to
find wording on the conflict that can
both win a majority and avoid a veto a
decision on the humanitarian aspects of
the current crisis will certainly not
redress the historic failure of the
security Council regarding the situation
in the Middle East it will however is
stop further human suffering now the
United States made what it thought has
been missing from past attempts action
moved to the general assembly where
member states were asked to vote for a
resolution that was grossly one-sided
and was missing two key words Hamas and
hostage meanwhile the United Nations
says 64 of its Aid workers have been
killed in Gaza and with 640,000
Palestinians crammed into un schools and
hospitals their warning of a breakdown
in civil order if humanitarian needs are
not soon met Christen salumi Al jazer
the United
Nations make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz